[Music]
welcome back to
another episode of what's a prof good
day walter
hello martin how are you doing i'm doing
actually quite fine
yes i'm also doing fine yes maybe it's
the calm before the storm
yes literally and figuratively literally
and figuratively
let's pray our heavenly father thank you
very much for bringing us together
we ask that you please bless our
conversation and also enlighten our
minds
we thank you in jesus name amen amen
well we're going to speak about climate
change famines pestilences
and earthquakes and it's not
going to be an environmental lecture
we're going to
look at the next step in the great saga
[Music]
so we've had a a preparation
for implementing all of those things in
the bible
that everybody is waiting for
the possibility for controlling buying
and selling has become a real reality
over the last few months
the control of what you may believe and
what you may not believe has become
a real reality the control of what you
may say and what you may
not say have become a real reality
yes your choice yes
and your expression of your choice
uh can be detailed
absolutely so we're going to talk about
what the possible next step will be
because we've picked up quite some
momentum
and i don't believe that the powers that
be
will let this opportunity pass by in
fact many of them have said
that this is the great opportunity
that's why we spoke about the great
reset recently
so the bible warns us
that just before the end there will be
an increase in calamities
and the climate agenda is very much
aware of calamities and
wants to use this to bring about
certain changes in human behavior
so let's look at what has been happening
in the world
matthew 24 7 says for nation shall
rise against nation and kingdom against
kingdom
and there shall be famines and
pestilences
and earthquakes in diverse places
in other words it'll be in universal
not just local events and we will have
ethnic groups against each other and
we've seen the black lives matter
movement
and we've seen all of these
movements to drive nation against
nation and kingdom against kingdom and
we have
lots of rumors about china and the
united states
and various others that are at
loggerheads with each other yes
and the possibility of famines has
become a real reality
yes especially they say that
the covet crisis can disrupt
the supply lines and eventually this
could lead to
famines pestilences well i think we've
we've exhausted the topic earthquakes
in diverse places all of these things
are happening
yep and never before at this scale right
it's at the
intensity absolutely
now we've put together here this little
video about
all of the natural disasters that have
taken place
and you know some of them have actually
hit us personally right yes
and the video that we'll show is
not older than two or three weeks
exactly this is
everything that's up and this is only a
fraction i mean if you go to this
this channel you'll see it's
amazing what's wrapping right around the
world absolutely it is so
incredible all of the disasters that are
taking place
internationally right now and we are
experiencing some of them
yeah there's a cyclone that he
is hitting the southern african region
that's coming and
with the last one my trees were rubbed
out
yes my branches were everywhere i
thought i would
hang on to my hat away i thought that
was going to be somewhere else
and it was and uh i was particularly
upset about my two
no three fruit trees that gave up the
ghost in that wind
yeah nevertheless
uh cyclone chalane
[Music]
in december 2020 and we are expecting
the next one within
two days from this recording so we
are preparing for what is coming and
these things are really happening
let's look
[Music]
this
oh yeah
so ranging from japan saudi arabia
manchester in england turkey turkey
and that and there's brazil so
everywhere argentina you can carry on
record cold
record hearts all the extremes that we
can imagine
and this cyclone eloise that's hurtling
towards us
so i'm going to tie down my trees i
don't know whether that'll help
but no it won't so we'll just see
if if you have my trees next next week
then
you welcome to them try and plant them
again
so we have these massive disasters
the world will say is there's something
wrong is there a solution is there
something we can do about it
then the bible said that there will be
earthquakes in various places
and they're too numerous to mention yeah
so let's just take those that are
happening
right now in the ambit of this
discussion
i literally went and put in earthquake
in google
pressed enter and we picked the first
two that came up
exactly 19th of january magnitude 6.4
chile argentine all of these
areas were affected
and then in south cotabato in the
philippines
we had a seven magnitude earthquake
and these things are happening all the
time
in various places and never at this
intensity and this frequency yes and you
can check those records back
over years and there is a tremendous
increase in frequency
so yes these things are happening
and then natural disasters are augmented
by
not so natural disasters so
there was a power failure in romania on
the 18th of january
the bachelic reported on this
i see you've translated it into english
almost unnoticed europe scratched past
the momentous
mega blackout again on friday already a
week earlier there was a blackout risk
for
unexplained reasons this time a crack
in the electricity grid was announced as
the cause
due to a disturbance in southeastern
europe
frightening great reset author
klaus schwab has already warned
of a major attack on the european
electricity supply and called such
a scenario a cyber pandemic
so we have real pandemics and then we
have
cyber pandemics some of them
may be planned like hacking the internet
system and some of them not planned
now it's interesting how everything is
interconnected if something happens in
romania
then the whole of europe will be
affected right
because everything has become integrated
so one floor one link of the chain that
goes
and you have a problem so electricity
communications water food supply
everything would come to a halt and
we've had a few of those
in the united states and we here in
africa well to us it's it's part of our
lifestyle right yes
we have power outages all the time
and i don't think people overseas really
understand
what it's like living under those
circumstances
and the covet 19 crisis would be
regarded in this regard as a small
disturbance compared to a large
cyber attack and they
constantly referred to what schwab had
to say
on this issue the loss of power and
control in a large
region region over a longer period of
time would have
serious consequences for companies
governments
and societies in the broader sense
that would be like going back to the
middle ages
now what did class schwab actually have
to say
about this let's listen to what the man
says
one of the most striking and exciting
transformations
caused by the dynamic has been our
transition
to the digital of everything both
in our professional but also in our
personal lives
it has come in a very short time
and technology has been central to the
way
we have collectively managed also the
kobe 19
crisis this paradigm shift
to digital has made the role
of cyber security as a global public
good
even more pronounced amidst the pandemic
cyber criminals have also
been quick to exploit the increased
vulnerabilities
and the increased use that came along
the world economic forum recently
published a kobe 19 risks outlook
the third greatest concern for companies
surveyed
is the increase of cyber attacks
we all know but still
pay insufficient attention
to the frightening scenario of a
comprehensive cyber attack
which would bring to a complete halt
to the power supply transportation
hospital services our society as a whole
the kubai 19 crisis would be seen
in this respect as a small disturbance
in comparison to a major
cyber attack we have to ask ourselves
in such a situation how could we let
this happen despite the fact we had
all the information about
the possibility and the seriousness
of a risk attack
so what do you think about that martin
well if i think back to our previous
episode
on the games that they played and
scenarios that they worked out
this also almost sounds like a scenario
that's going to play itself out
so do you think they might have a
practice run as to what will happen
when there is such an event that takes
place let's have it
we'll have to wait and see and will the
world be prepared for when it comes
well according to what he says no they
were going to say why didn't we
do anything about this earlier all right
now
no matter what this man says or that man
says
we know from the bible that there will
be
disasters and a time of trouble
such as never was
and when you see these things this is
the beginning of birth pains
and out of that will come
a moral legislation
that will finally be the last straw
on the camel's back are we heading in
that direction
yes are you sure definitely
the thing that you just mentioned as
well
the start of the birth planes if you go
back
in history you can see the start of the
birth pains already
there so the intensity of the birth
pains
gives you an indication of where we are
yes
you know what surprises me i think
that we are
at that moment in history when we have
the
greatest opportunity ever
to proclaim the warnings of revelation
chapter 14.
and i am stunned that so many people
are totally silent on the issue
the greatest opportunity to spread the
message of warning
where everybody is looking and wondering
what is happening to the world
yes are we going to go out with a
whimper
yes are we gonna sit and no
don't worry it's just the glitch on the
horizon don't worry
no it just surprises me i am stunned i
thought
everybody will climb on the barricades
and use this opportunity to warn the
world for what is coming
because the world wants answers at this
stage yes
and it doesn't help them you're telling
them no this is just how it should be
let's use the bible and tell them no the
bible
showed us this is how it's going to be
and what's coming
absolutely so what do they want to do
about climate change what are their
plans let's look at some of the plans
here's an interesting article from the
11th of january
2021 and it says a bill gates
venture aims to spray dust into the
atmosphere
to block the sun what could go wrong
you know they want to spray a lot of
things these days
one wonders where all of these sprays
are going
microsoft's billionaire founder bill
gates is financially
backing the development of sun dimming
technology you know
when you think about sun dimming
one volcano that erupts can lower the
earth's temperature
by a degree and
if you have a number of them erupting at
the same time or you use this
technology you might be surprised to end
up with an ice age right
uh we're already seeing record low
temperatures in the world
so it's not weather's record high
temperatures we've got both of those
we've got both of those so do they have
a real climate model as to say what
would happen
or is this just another experiment
so that would potentially reflect
sunlight out of the earth's atmosphere
triggering
a global cooling effect the stratopheric
controlled perturbation experiment
and it has an acronym launched by
harvard university scientists
aims to examine this solution by
spraying
non-toxic calcium carbonate dust into
the atmosphere
a sun reflecting aerosol that may offset
the effects
of global warming
widespread research into the efficacy of
solar geoengineering has been
stalled for years due to controversy
opponents believe such science comes
with unpredictable risks
including extreme shifts in weather
patterns not dissimilar
to warming trends we have or already
been witnessing
so again they are playing
with nature now if you
if you come from a biblical perspective
who designed nature
god and has it been working
meticulously now for however long the
earth has existed
yes yes and now in the last moments we
want to
tweak it and change it well
if if i can put it like this
for me it's the lord said in the bible
we will have these things starting to
deteriorate
yes so this is just another human
way to try and save ourselves the earth
will wear out like a garment what does
that mean
it will start going disintegrating
there's always
the promise also that harvest will not
decline until the end comes
except that right at the end there will
be major
kilometers so environmentalists
similarly fear that a dramatic
shift in mitigation strategy will be
treated as a green light to continue
emitting
greenhouse gases with little to no
changes in current consumption
and production patterns you know it's
fascinating that
that one volcano can put more co2 into
the atmosphere than all of humanity
combined
and what would you do in a case like
that would you be able to curtail that
if a natural disaster
contributes more than human intervention
so all of these things are interesting
because humanity
is trying to solve a problem that god
said would be
inevitable correct
here's another one the conversation this
comes from december 8 2020
dimming the sun could reduce future
drought risk
in cape town but there's a catch
despite a recent slight decline due to
the covet 19 pandemic
greenhouse gas emissions continue to
accumulate in the atmosphere
they are projected to rise again once
the economy
recovers more radical proposals to
reduce
climate change risks are being debated
amongst these
is solar geoengineering about which we
just spoke in the previous slide
also called solar radiation management
or
modification the most commonly proposed
solar radiation
management technique involves the
deliberate injection of
sulfur aerosols into the stratosphere
the layer of the atmosphere around 15
kilometers above
earth's surface to create a thin veil
that would reflect a small amount of
sunlight back to space
this in turn would cool earth and offset
greenhouse gas
warming i also say here in this last
paragraph
also solar geo engineering
wouldn't return the climate to a
pre-industrial state
in fact offsetting global warming using
solar radiation management
could increase drought risk in asia
the sahel and the south america so
you might improve one area and create a
problem in another area so it's again
one of those
unknowns right so how do you
deal with this do we interfere
or do we not interfere that
is the question
what do we glean from the spirit of
prophecy
it says here in the southern watchmen
it is on the law of god that the last
great struggle of the controversy
between christ and his angels and satan
and his angels will come
that's just to put us back onto the real
issues correct all of these others are
distractions yes
it's every time trying to bring it back
see where all these loose ends tie up to
where they tie up and it will be
decisive for all the world men
in responsible positions will not only
ignore
and despise the sabbath themselves
but from the sacred desk will urge upon
the people the observance of the first
day of the week
pleading tradition and custom in behalf
of this
man-made institution
they will point to the calamities on
land and sea
to the storms of wind the floods the
earthquakes the destruction by
fire as judgments indicating god's
displeasure because sunday is not
sacredly observed
i listened to a conspiratorial
webpage the other day to a talk
there and i'm amazed to see
how people think how they distort the
scriptures
and how they they come to the conclusion
that we are all gods
which was the first lie in the garden of
eden in any case and it's the new age
philosophy
and many of these people that are
on this bandwagon
will say that we are gods and that the
real enemy is the god of the old
testament yeah
isn't that amazing and the god of the
old testament
and his laws must be overcome
because jesus said that the wine bibbers
and the tax collectors and the
prostitutes
should be left alone they should remain
as they are but then they end off with
this interesting thing is
that the sign of his resurrection the
sunday
is the day that should be kept and
celebrated
so that they're putting the new
testament against the old testament
rather than the old testament being the
gospel in type and the new testament
being the gospel in verity and that
there is no difference between the god
of the old testament and the god of the
new testament
and that jesus didn't come to change the
law at all
and not one jot or one tittle should by
any means disappear from the law
and they they totally confuse it yeah
they're saying that jesus
with the sunday comes to take away this
god of the old testament yes with his
sabbath and
then they said that this final battle
will be to get rid of those people that
cling
to the old the old god and this and he
said and
i'm absolutely stunned how they twisted
around
well the new one is legal
the new way but it's not lawful it's not
lawful because the
old testament is the lawful we've got
a new phrase now that we're going to
play with right
so they will point to these calamities
on land and see them to the storms of
wind and flood and earthquakes to the
destruction
by fire as we've seen in california as
judgments indicating god's displeasure
because sunday is not sacredly observed
so far they are saying that these
calamities are happening
because god is displeased yes
so these calamities will increase more
and more one disaster will follow close
upon the heels of another
and those who make void the law of god
will point to the few
who are keeping the sabbath of the
fourth commandment as the ones who are
bringing wrath upon the world
now that's exactly the type of thing i
was listening to and this is
exactly what they are saying
and this is the war that is happening in
the minds of people in the united states
in particular at the moment yeah because
it might
seem a little bit at this state
disjointed
yes but it's all clinging together it's
all
starting to move together so this
falsehood is satan's device that remains
snare
the unwary so we've moved from
one set of calamities
to another set and we've heard before
that climate change will make the
pandemic
look like child's play yeah
and then the great deceiver will
persuade men that those who serve god
are causing these evils i actually heard
that
in that discussion the class that have
provoked the displeasure of heaven
will charge all their troubles upon
those whose obedience to god's
commandments
is a perpetual reproof to transgressors
it will be declared that men are
offending god
by violating the sunday sabbath that
this sin
has brought calamities which will not
cease until sunday observance shall be
strictly enforced
and that those who present the claims of
the fourth commandment thus destroying
reverence for sunday
are troublers of the people preventing
their restoration to divine
favor and temporal prosperity
thus the accusation urged of old against
the servant of god will repeat it
and upon grounds equally well
established
and then there is this quote and it came
to pass when ahab saw
elijah that aba ahab said unto him art
thou he that troubleth israel
and he answered i have not troubled
israel
but thou and thy father's house in that
year forsaken the commandments of the
lord
and thou hast followed balaam 1 kings 18
17 and 18 as the wrath of the people
shall be excited by
false charges they will pursue a course
towards
god's ambassadors very similar to that
which apostate
israel pursued towards elijah
martin do you think they will talk about
re-education camps definitely
if they can talk about re-education
trump followers
and many of the trump followers are the
very ones that are
making those statements that i just
quoted yes do you think it is possible
that it will get to this stage
yes so just clarify what you've said now
again i said that
that talk that i spoke but i don't want
to
put it on to but that talk was a was
religious
that was a religious talk yes that talk
was
telling that the old testament god is
the enemy the enemy
jesus jesus is the one who will defeat
that old testament god
and destroy his laws
and then set up his kingdom
and that sunday will play a pivotal role
in that and those were people that
were of the conservative side i just
wanted to make that clear yes
so this roth will increase and we'll
have a very similar
situation this was the great type
and the anti-type is awaiting us
is another statement and then the great
deceiver will persuade men to charge
all their troubles on those whose
obedience to god's commandment
is a perpetual reproof to the
transgressors
it will be declared that men offend god
by the violation of sunday
that this sin has brought calamities
which will not cease until sunday
observance shall be strictly enforced
and those who destroy the reverence for
sunday are preventing
restoration of divine favor and
prosperity
thus the accusations urged of old
against the servant of
god will be repeated when aj ahab saw
elijah
etc so this is what we can expect
i wonder whether ahab thought that
the climate change that occurred in his
day
was as a result of some natural
phenomena
because why did he eventually accused
god's people
why did he being a disturber of yeah
preventing the prosperity and
you know mankind is beginning to think
in that direction
here's one from the review and herald
march 18 1884
the lord has a controversy with his
professed people in these last days
in this controversy men in responsible
positions
will take a course directly opposite
that pursued by
nehemiah they will not only ignore and
despise the sabbath themselves but they
will try to keep it from
others by burying it beneath the rubbish
of custom and tradition
in churches and in large gatherings in
the open
air ministers will urge upon the people
the necessity of keeping the first day
of the week
there are calamities on sea and land and
these calamities will
increase one disaster following close
upon another
and the little band of conscientious
sabbath keepers will be pointed out
as the ones who are bringing the wrath
of god upon the world
by their disregard of sunday
this is the pattern this is what has
been taught
for more than 100 years right correct
we'll read one more this is an
interesting one this
comes from three manuscript releases
page 314
about the cities when god's restraining
hand is removed
the destroyer begins his work
then in our cities the greatest
calamities will come
is this because people do not keep
sunday
no because men have trampled upon the
law of java the lord is slow to anger
this should inspire the heart with
gratitude the lord is slow to anger
and great in power and will not at all
acquit the wicked the lord has his way
in the world wind
and in the storm and the clouds of the
dust of his feet
quoting nahum so some of these disasters
will be because god withdraws his
restraining power
and maybe some of them will be judgments
yes so even the religious leaders will
climb onto this bandwagon
and we read that protestantism shall
give the hand of fellowship to the roman
power
then there will be a law against the
sabbath of god's creation
and then it is that god will do his
strange
work in the earth
this is what is happening in the world
and
we must see where we are in the stream
of time right
here is fox business news from 20
january 2021 and it says
environmental activists pushing for
compulsory climate change
education worldwide as part
of the paris agreement now we know that
the pope's encyclical
on climate change lo da to c
has a very prominent role to play in
this
and we've said it over and over let's
say it again
is sunday part of that encyclical
definitely absolutely and
is it one of the the ways in which they
can combat climate change by
compulsory sunday keeping yes yes
i think if i'm correct it's paragraph
thank you i'm very proud of you
article 12 of the paris agreement
already states that
nations shall cooperate in taking
measures as appropriate to enhance
climate change
education training public awareness
public participation
and public asset access to information
recognizing the importance of these
steps with respect to enhancing
actions under this agreement so the
public must be involved
at every level then earthday.org a u.s
group that builds itself as the world's
largest recruiter to the environmental
movement
is working with trade unions and
environmental groups around the world to
ensure that climate change
education is compulsory
under the paris agreement
education that's what the pope asked for
it is not that
re-education yes he wants education
camps and you've got the pope that goes
on
about the education so everybody must be
clued up on climate change
a cry for survival comes from the planet
itself
president biden said in his inaugural
address
and the first thing he did was rejoin
a cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear now
so the world is moving in the direction
that prophecy
has foretold
here is an article from the national
catholic reporter
and it's earthbeat stories of climate
crisis
faith and action and it says 2021
seen as a year to make up lost ground
on climate change you know martin
trump went out of the climate accord
right correct
and yet he stated that the united states
has done more
in harmony with the climate accord than
any other nation
and now they're saying they must make up
lost ground
even though trump had said that he had
made
up a lost lost round
so within the u.s that means a new
president
and new democratic majority in congress
making up four years environmental
deregulation and de-emphasis
on addressing the growing climate crisis
under president donald trump
at the international level it means
making up for
missed deadlines after cop 26.
and within the catholic church it means
making up momentum to begin a wider
deeper implementation of pope francis's
2015 encyclical lo dato c
on the care for our common home what
does that mean
making up momentum to begin a wider
deeper implementation of la
da to see breathe each sleep
does that mean sunday legislation yep
was it uh just a tiny mention or was
that quite a
component in low dart to see yeah it's
quite a component
it's a very important rest for the earth
absolutely
as part of the continuing lauda to see
here
the vatican plans to hold its third
round table
at the world economic forum in davos
switzerland
it has also explored a possible spring
gathering
of religious leaders
the special year is set to conclude in
may
with a conference possibly an encyclical
inspired
global musical performance that isn't
that interesting i think they're setting
up an image
and they're going to have all kinds of
music in the plane of durham that's
right
now i wonder what all kinds of music is
only
godly music you know it always surprises
me
how people that are even avowed
satanists become
knights and are dubbed nights
and become sir whatever their name
is in the world today and there is no
difference made between those
that worship the devil
absolutely in the open and write songs
to him and those that don't
and i was also interested at the about
the the musical environment
of the inauguration exactly just wanted
to mention that and his choice
of musicians was fascinating to say the
least right
and their dress also sent a number of
messages exactly
and the color of the dress and even the
color of the
the dignitaries like the vice president
for example
uh what they were wearing very
reminiscent
reminiscent of what the simpsons had
i i find all of these things very
interesting but the truth
is conspiratorial again don't go there
okay so after these musical performances
they will have
and the first lao da to see awards
what's that martin well it's probably
going to be like the same like the
grammy awards
or something like that were you honored
for how good you keep the doubt to see
whatever the end of the laudato sea year
will also mark the beginning of the
laudato si
action platform i think we are heading
for
some exciting things in the future
and 2020 with all of its excitement
will seem like a walk in the park
compared to what
is coming right yep
the platform set to launch on may 24 is
a project
of the diecastry for promoting
integral human development which has
invited catholic institutions of all
types and sizes to commit to a
seven year journey to become totally
sustainable
in the spirit of the integral ecology of
laudatusi i hope
for our sake and the planet's sake that
that seven
year period will be cut dramatically
that's just on hope
the guardian reports biden to hit the
ground running
as he rejoins the paris climate
accords joe biden is set for a flurry of
action to combat the climate crisis
on his first day as president by
immediately rejoining the paris climate
agreement
and blocking the keystone xl pipeline
although experts have warned lengthier
and harder environmental
battles lie ahead in his presidency
day one biden will rejoin
paris regulate methane emissions and
continue
taking many other aggressive executive
climate actions in the opening days and
weeks of his presidency
so we're going to see some executive
orders right
now martin is that legal or is it lawful
legal it's legal right okay
let's get back to the prophetic picture
it seemed under trump as if there was a
rift between rome and the united states
and now under biden it seems that that
wound is healed right so the vatican
news
tells us 19 january 2020
one the time to heal the wounds in the
united states
the united states is still shaken by
what happened on the 6th of january
during the assault on capitol hill which
resulted in the death
of five people it is therefore no
coincidence that the theme
chosen by the new president joe biden
for his swearing-in ceremony
is america united
let's continue down here the united
states needs to realize
that unfulfilled dream of harmony
and equality so this is pope francis
speaking himself
and he said that the united states needs
to realize that
unfulfilled dream of harmony and
equality
a dream that always remains relevant and
indeed becomes even
more urgent in a country where despite
the great economic opportunities there
remain
injustices and social conflicts
that have also now been exacerbated by
the pandemic
this is therefore the time to let us
prevail over me
to heal wounds and find a renewed unity
based on those principles
that have always sustained american
democracy and made
it a protagonist on the international
scene it's interesting that they always
use this terminology of healing the
wound
yeah this is an internal healing but
it's also a healing with the
relationships with
the internationally yeah this
awareness must not just remain an
utterance but
quoting fratelli tutti requires a
concrete
efforts at all levels this is even
more true today in a historic period in
which despite
centrifugal forces and nationalistic
interests
the pandemic has dramatically shown that
no one is saved alone
so he reiterates that statement that no
one
is saved alone you have to have a group
salvation
martin is that biblical no
absolutely not you will stand before the
judgment seat
alone for your decision i cannot hide
behind the decision by a pope
a prelate or anyone who wants to decide
for me
what is right or what is wrong yes and
hasn't become
quite prevalent in the last few weeks
how your choice
is being curtailed absolutely you can
what i mean is you cannot speak out
on what your choice is if it's not in
harmony with what the common
good feels it should be you're not
allowed to up to outer your voice
correct here's religious news services
and they say with his inauguration
biden makes his return to catholic
washington
that's a very interesting statement
don't you think yeah
when he marched off the capitol grounds
later in the day
he re-entered a much larger group a
peculiar hyper-political faith community
that makes the nation's capital one of
the most active and
ardent catholic centers
has there been a takeover in the united
states of america
catholicism is the majority religion
on the supreme court and catholic or not
the justices
along with many notables in the
capital's judicial community
typically attend the annual red mass
at the cathedral adsense matthew the
apostles
celebrating those in the legal
profession so there they all
attend this celebration of the mass and
by the way
the mass as you know is a perpetual
sacrifice
when jesus said he was sacrificed once
for all so this is totally unbiblical
yes
and then another piece of interesting
information
from the religious news service joe
biden's family bible anchors
faith-infused
inaugural events now what is his family
bible
it's a doa reimspire are you sure yes
president-elect joe biden plans to be
sworn in
with his hefty family bible when he
becomes the 46th
president of the united states on
wednesday
january the 20th which has now already
taken place
it's one of many ways religion will be a
facet of the inaugural activities
surrounding the country's second
catholic president it's just been a
family heirloom
on the biden side of the family and
every important date
is in there biden said in a december
appearance on the late show
with stephen colbert every time i've
been sworn in for anything
the date has been on that and it's
inscribed in
the bible before the inaugural
ceremony the reverend kevin o'brien
president of santa clara university and
a jesuit priest will officiate
a mass biden will be attending with a
bipartisan delegation wednesday morning
at the cathedral of saint matthew
so martin here is the picture of this
bible
and it says holy bible juay rhymes
now the jewel rhymes bible is the jesuit
counter-reformation bible yes
written explicitly to counter the bibles
that came
out of the protestant stable yes
this bible is based of course on the
latin
vulgate and not on the receive text as
the protestant bibles were
and i wonder whether some jots or
tittles
could have been changed in that
bible let's have a look let's have a
look
now this is the bible that they are
putting on display
and if they do this so publicly
then they are telling protestants
directly
that they have superseded them
made america catholic and destroyed
protestantism
and the very basis of protestantism
which is sola scriptura
this is a war on god's word correct
this is a in your face against the
protestant reformation
yes let's have a look
acts chapter 15 verse 23
king james version and they wrote
letters
by them after this manner the apostles
and elders and brethren sent
greetings unto the brethren
which are of the gentiles in antioch
and syria and seleccia
so when the council came together we've
used this text before
but let's just clarify it again when
that early church council came together
they decided as a group and wrote a
letter
on behalf of the entire church and
the ones that were in the
decision-making were the
apostles and the elders
and the brethren and then
they sent greetings unto the dispersed
brethren in other regions
and gave the decision so it was a church
decision
if you take the jewelry rhymes they've
added some punctuation
writing by their hands the apostles and
ancients
comma that's a title
brethren to the brethren of the gentiles
that
are at antioch and in syria and seleccia
greetings now
by changing a tittle
they have changed something which is
lawful
into something that is according to them
legal
but no longer lawful so
this is like degrees of comparison
if you take the niv which is their other
masterpiece even though nobody wants to
admit it but jesuits were on these
committees
yes it says in acts 15
23 with them they sent the following
letter
the apostles and elders comma
now it's not brethren but your brothers
to the gentile believers in antioch
syria
and silesia so the model that the bible
has
is that a decision of major importance
must be undertaken by the leaders of the
church
together with delegations of the whole
then a decision must be made they have
changed it here
to a hierarchy apostles
and ancients that sent the letters to
the other brethren in the niv
they completed this travesty of justice
and formalized it by saying the apostles
and
elders comma your brothers which
is a reference to the apostles and
elders
have lifted them above the rest and they
become the decision-making body
so in the roman catholic church you have
the pope and the magisterium
that decides for everybody what they
should believe
it's not biblical no they've changed
a title a comma and have
made a totally different legal
construct which is against
the law of god
any ecclesiastical body that does the
same
is transgressing the law
but it seems legal but it's not
lawful all right so that's the one
problem
this bible the jewish rhymes
and all the modern bibles that
follow suit are actually
changing the construct of
the bible not one jot or one turtle
shall by any means be
changed and yet they have done it let's
take another example
genesis chapter 3 verse 15. this is the
great
promise of redemption yes and i will put
enmity between thee
and the woman in other words between you
satan
and god's church
and between thy seed the followers
of the doctrines of devils yes and her
seed
those that follow the bible
and it shall bruise thy head
who's that jesus the seed of the woman
which is singular which is jesus shall
bruise or crush
the head of the devil and thou
shalt bruise his masculine
heal that's the king james version this
is the great controversy
between christ and satan the followers
of satan and the followers of christ
yes and the great promise and the great
promise that
the enemy will be destroyed his head
will be crushed
by jesus by jesus now the jew
rhymes the one that has now been used to
swear in a president
says i will put enmities between thee
and the woman now that is now
taking this woman and taking it out of
context
in terms of the biblical identification
of the bride
of christ as a woman and making it mary
then they continue and thy seed
and her seed then she
shall crush thy head and thou shalt lay
in wait for her
heel so now the war is not between
christ
and satan but between mary yes
and satan but if you take
the occult reversal then it is actually
the war against jesus christ
so we now have let's put it this way an
occult bible that a president has been
using to be inaugurated
and that occult bible says exactly the
opposite
to what the protestant bible says this
is a serious issue you cannot
mess with one shot or one title
in the bible
so this movement for sunday protection
is increasing worldwide and here is the
alliance for the free sunday participate
and protect sunday and
we've had this one on the screen before
but this sunday issue they say
is pivotal for the time that we are
living in yes
they admit that some work on sunday must
be done
for example in hospitals the police
and some restaurants perhaps
and cafes but
it should be greatly reduced
on a sunday here is a webpage from
the evangelicals in europe
and they say that they have
planned many things for the year 2021.
now it's interesting that this all
coincides
with what has been happening in the
united states of america
then will be the jubilee of the edict
of constantine the emperor
on from the year 321
and they want to celebrate this this
alliance for the free
sunday on the 3rd of march 2021 will be
the first celebrations we've mentioned
this before
here they say we protect and value
this common time period
for the seventh day but the sunday is
not the seventh day it's the first day
of the week
yes and here they say that they are
planning an
economical church day in frankfurt
from the 12th to the 16th of may in
many places and in different formats
to bring this theme of a free sunday
to the minds of the people so this is an
ecommerical effort
that means all the churches yes every
single church that is associated with
the economical council
is going to be involved i'm sure this
will go inside with jubilee for the
earth
and all those movements sundays for the
so they're going to bring climate
together definitely and they're going to
bring lodar to sea into the picture
and they're going to bring their
celebrations into the picture
is there a movement to bring sunday to
the fall
definitely will there be disasters and
earthquakes
in various places and pestilences in the
mix
and the um labor unions are involved
and they will be one of the means to
bring about a time of trouble such as
never was do you think
that the stage is said
that the final events portrayed in
prophecy
could unfold definitely so martin
has the table being said yes
do we have for the first time all
the parameters in place for these events
to actually come to fruition
definitely now what if somebody would
throw a spanner in the works
i mean donald trump made some
interesting
illusions when he held his last
speech at the andrews air force base
and he said that there will be
tremendous things happening and he used
the economy
as an example and he said
see you soon and there's a lot of
speculation on that
and some of the conspiracists are going
crazy
and saying that there will be a complete
change of events and that soon
some of them i've read will say we will
see the inauguration of the 19th
president of the united states now
we're way past number 19 so where do
they get that
and they're of course talking about the
corporation
versus the real so the legal versus
the fiction and all of these interesting
things
but you know what be that as it may
will it change prophecy no it won't
right
because prophecy said what will happen
and everything is in
place for those things to happen so no
matter
what surprise yes comes our way
it won't change the course of prophecy
the outcome will eventually be the same
exactly because we are dealing with
scripture here
and scripture cannot be changed
it cannot be altered and god said
see i tell you ahead of time
so that when it does happen
you will believe yes right
amen so i would like to end
on this verse in luke chapter 21 verse
and when these things begin to come to
pass
then look up and lift up your heads
for your redemption draweth nigh
martin i believe we are on the threshold
of great events great trouble yes
unfortunately no buying no selling
great perplexity but when these things
begin to come to pass
then lift up your heads for your
redemption
draweth nigh isn't this verse
one of the reasons why we sit with a
smile
and talk about serious things yes
because
you know there are so many things that
are depressing in the world
but if you have this faith yes that soon
this suffering on this earth will be
over
and there will be no more enemy
and you're looking forward to it i i
can't wait
then if these things start happening you
can't help but talking with it with a
smile
yeah about it with let's pray
that god's people will wake up it's time
that god's church
starts sounding the loud cry absolutely
and stop being afraid because the bible
says
perfect faith drives
out fear amen let's pray
heavenly father you have said when these
things happen we should lift up our
heads because
our redemption draweth nigh
we thank you that you have prophesied
these things and that we can discern
the very events taking place in the
world today
which are leading up to this very
culmination
of the history of this world give your
people
the insight and the foresight
and the further to preach the message of
salvation
in the context of the three angels
now while the day still lasts
because the night is coming and also
the day in jesus name i pray amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you